[Music]
hey Samuel leaves here welcome to
winners on a Wednesday this week we have
a guy who's been in the game a little
while please welcome onto the show mr.
trevor kuba hi good tag on the show man
it's me you've any pockets a long time
why don't you start by just giving us a
little bit about your your background
how long do you have any property what
you've done
yeah okay so I started in profit about
20 years ago that was before I was in
property yeah that was before I left
school thanks for rubbing in yeah you
probably were about six I think
yeah well seven all right yeah yeah but
that's a long time yeah so talk talk us
through what you've wanted I know you've
you've recently where you're attended
the crash course what like a year ago in
June in June yeah
and things have changed a little bit and
strategies are changed you now step it
out and do things a little bit
differently but why don't you just talk
to us a little bit about what you don't
try to the crash course yeah and what
your strategy is Ben York so I mean it
all started
I've had a career of hella creating
sounds on the life yeah and at one point
there was a bit of a changing in the
industry of working and I was made
redundant several times in a row I
thought you know what I've got to find
some way of making sure that I'm secure
financially and it's not going to be
from income coming from another company
and that was it so we rapid got a little
on holiday on wife and I we were
thinking about doing it by tiller and
before we got home we'd already booked
all the viewings for when we got back
and we started getting really excited
and we went and bought a one-bedroom
house little tiny house and we didn't
know what we were doing had no idea
every we decorated it I was out there 3
a.m. in the morning painting the windows
getting it already took us a week to
turn around put it back on the market
and it left straightaway Wow fantastic
so that's kind of where it started and
then fast forward to about four years
ago I left my day job
we've just got to a point where we could
cover all of our costs without vital
airs so I thought actually you know what
I will eat today job and do some other
stuff and yeah so incredible so you
single-handedly built this property I
mean how many properties did you take it
all if you decide you know what we came
out like and I leave work at that point
it was eight properties hey and what
these were all single apps or single and
reasonably in my world very low yielding
yeah what kind of return on investment
were you getting so it's probably about
seven or eight percent about seven or
eight percent which is hey it's a lot
better than the bank yeah and you're
also getting caps depreciation but it's
very I say this at the cross currency
retailers you could literally buy a
property blindfolded yeah you know in a
random area and just be like that one
and you still probably go to make money
over time the dangerous way to make
money in property is like things are off
plan overseas that can go wrong but if
you just put your money into property
you're probably gonna make money which
is which is what you did it is exactly
which is and you were we just put it in
25 percent deposits based on your income
yeah I think it's 20 percent in those
days but yeah we were just putting
deposit down we haven't saved up from
the app and the income and yeah so I
guess for anyone watching this who is I
mean put presumably you what what do you
say your previous job was on a cup and
maybe done done but what was the book
which is like round so sales okay I want
stuff whether you've been selling
everything from home pride foods through
to children's books more recently okay
so so for anyone watching this who's
making a decent living and then they're
in a job the key is you can get maybe
didn't it happened to you three times
yeah so the real smart thing used to do
is to just save invest and wait yeah so
that was your strategy talk to me about
what changed in June then when you can
run the cross course so I think for me
you know I left the left my days about
four years ago and then I bought a few
more properties in the same or similar
way with a bit more thought in terms of
where I was buying
and I'm looking at capital growth and
try and work out where I think I'm going
to see that but they're more recently
after than the crash course it really
made me think differently I haven't
bought in the HMOs yet but that was the
key driver for me to go on the course
get something else done to look at yeah
because I'm thinking now you know what
I've got a good really good asset base
I've got a reasonable amount of income
coming off of it but it'd be good to
bring that up a bit more and get you
high yielding properties and you've got
you you've got one which is a higher
return one just in a single there but
we're pushing about a little bit more
which is you're going to be getting the
keys when we get the keys on Monday
fantastic yeah are you excited about
that one very much so yeah awesome it's
a project with my my cell phone and my
son yeah so it's going to be his first
buy-to-let excellent yes couple weeks so
talk to me a little bit about some of
these because I know why you've come on
the show for three reasons one because I
asked you to come on because you've been
successful in property and because
you're now pushing about out you getting
more interesting deals secondly because
I know you want to inspire people yeah
you know you've got one of the things
that you do which is great on our
Facebook group and if anyone's not on
the property investors do something lean
to Facebook group I think they should
but you're very active on that and you
post your deals and you put spreadsheets
and yes I look these are the figures and
your site this is what I put in and this
is now I'm getting happen these are the
return on investment which is really
really good and it just means that
people can see the nitty-gritty of the
exact figures already appreciate that so
you're going through spire people and
three I see you getting a lot of
questions on the group about your
properties so we wanted to answer some
of the common questions around property
that I get that you get to really just
help people have value so why don't we
start why don't you just talk to me a
little bit about what are the common
questions that you've been asked and
what are the the key lessons that you
wish you knew now when you started 20
years yeah sure I don't think the key
one is is around capital growth and
where I see it is if I stopped learning
strategies the moment might must
actually been about buying properties
where I think there's going to be good
capital growth it's about how you
like those areas yeah and I mean I don't
[ __ ] with it right we'll find out
I've done okay in the past yeah so yeah
I think that that's a key one and that's
that's just about really doing the due
diligence and you know analyzing the
figures so for instance where I'm buying
at the moment yeah the prices haven't
moved since about 2006 yeah a lot people
go why are you buying there then that's
a terrible place to buy well actually
they're undervalued Yemen it's it's
loads of growth it I'm expecting that
area and when you drive to this area you
see all the builders there building
properties everywhere because I know
that that's gonna happen it's gonna grow
so yeah that's one thing I'm cause
that's a really good point
sometimes people jump like to jump on
the bandwagon yeah so they'll see you
know properties are gonna go going up in
an area and there's going crazy and then
it won't think all by their then example
actually you better off to find an area
which where prices are bottled out
because after a big dip will always be
follow a big boom and after a big boom
will always follow a big dip you know
yeah that's really interesting so where
are you buying at the moment then if you
don't want me ask you know not so um
hope it helped the prices go up well
yeah and so the one we're just doing is
in Crewe but most of the properties
we're buying that are actually in
Sandbach which is sort of next to Crewe
yeah really nice little town quite
affluent I know these are different
strategies the ones that some people
follow yeah but I'm looking for those
properties specifically for capital
growth but you're now getting a much
better return than you were going yeah
absolutely I mean 11 percent never seen
them like which is still it's we've got
a long way to go yet yeah yeah it's
better than 7 or 8 percent it's a
reasonable return on a single man yeah
and it says it's gonna be my son's first
property so for a first one single it's
probably not a bad idea
yeah and yeah and your figures as well
your figures are very very conservative
realistic factored into account
in fact we talk about everything and
more which is which is a good way to do
it because it you'd rather think 11
percent and then actually actually okay
it was full all the time brilliant it's
now 12 or 13 percent then think is could
it be 20 percent and then it's 15
percent so that's great okay well what
else what common questions do you get
then so I mean I think people say talk
about the area they then ask about
because they do look at that spreadsheet
better out there yeah and what coughs
and I get some really good comments
about that spreadsheet and some that I
just think really you're asking that you
know some people sort of say oh you know
you could get your oven for 50 quid or
less and you think okay great
it's not going to change the deal much
yeah but other people are still asking
more important questions about you know
how it's been financed and you know how
I'm getting to that overall number yeah
so it is about for me it is about
numbers
making sure you've got those numbers
just right yeah so yeah that spreadsheet
it's taken a while but you sort of come
up with a basic format and then you
build on it over time and now there's
nothing that's not on there so I know
when I run up like a property everything
I need will be included on that
spreadsheet fantastic really good and it
properties gotta be about formulas yes
too many people buy properties based on
their feelings yeah you know I like this
properties in a nice area but but
actually even with yourself looking for
capital appreciation it's not your
feelings it's your you calculating what
do we think it's going to go up well
I'll be
I'm glad you mention it because on the
really good podcasts that you do I
listen to Russell yeah and he was
talking about the formulas and feeling
things with Alastair and I think I wish
I could that should be their debate with
them at the time because they were
talking about the fact that will people
buying nice area it's nothing advise me
yeah but actually yeah I do but it's not
some buying my feelings it's just at my
strategy and my formula is to make sure
that my exit plan is that one
might want to sell that property or
reinvest or pull the money out and I
want the capital growth and that's why
I'm buying it
yeah yeah buying buying nice houses can
be about feelings it's about things and
that's the wrong motive but if you're
doing it and you've been you've got
planning minds that fit of your plan we
were talking earlier when we off-camera
about there's people say what's the best
property strategy there is not there is
none it just depends on what you're
wanting to achieve than everyone else
yeah and it will put different goals
almost to achieve different things so
love that what are your plans are now
moving forward now I know you did the
kruskal's in June you've now started
buying slightly different types of
properties how else did that change your
mindset strategies how else is that
because I helped I think I think the
challenge for me is now without going to
HMOs because clearly you know what
you've shown on that course can be
really good and it's about yeah for me
it's almost a challenge to me to say
come on do something a bit different
yeah and improve that cash flow because
we've got the assets so yeah I'm
certainly talking to agents in a
different way when I'm on the phone
which is something you talked about the
course I did on the program probably a
usually speaking line and you know that
propertied with my crew you know that
that one was very much from a
conversation you know I knew I knew
before I viewed it that there was going
to be movement in that price and that
was really important yeah so yeah it's
it's definitely maybe even think
differently it's also fired me up and
actually my family and you know that
that's really good because you're you're
really yes your son is now getting into
property a little bit and you're really
excited about seeing him and pursue that
journey tell me a little bit about that
yeah at the crash course he came to the
first day unfortunately not very well he
had to go home so we're gonna do it
again yeah at some point but yeah we for
him you know we don't quite know which
route he want to take yet but I suspect
he may well look at some of the other
strategies
you talk about and I that's one really
king that he gets involved now because I
think some of those strategies that you
look at would be very interesting for
him as he starts to build cash flow from
a very low base you know that's less
important to me but for him it's it's
kind of what he needs so that you can
then use that cash flow to go build his
assets mmm you talk about what have been
the biggest challenges as a property
investor over the two decades lack of
knowledge and I say that because it's
like you said earlier if I yeah what I
know now if I knew that even ten years
ago yeah in 2008 I was one of the people
who was thinking hold back do anything I
wished I had yeah and what's really
frustrating is I was in a position where
I could've died actually if I didn't
know you know I was still working in a
corporate career this was very much a
sideline I wasn't really deep diving in
terms of working out what the markets
actually doing yeah we was gonna go to
probably 2013 that's and they thought
hang on a minute
things are moving here I won best hours
I have a ball I bought in 2013 and it
was that [ __ ] off it was just found a
corn for a living less left worth which
is [ __ ] [ __ ] hot food [ __ ] it's really
interesting because I mean I've been
buying properties now for 1112 years and
one of the things that people don't
really see I don't think they appreciate
until you've been in the game for a very
long time is that when properties go up
in value that's when you hit the jackpot
really isn't it yeah but the returns are
fantastic and and making ten percent
twenty percent whatever you make it is
brilliant but really when you make the
big bucks it's when you suddenly go oh
my goodness I bought that property for a
hundred grand and now it's worth two
hundred thousand pounds and then you can
then refinance and do all kinds of
things with it all I don't think if you
ever played the game cash flow what I
want I have yeah yes are you good at it
do you win sometimes would you think the
way that I always win on cosplay 101 I
think the strategy which is very true to
real life is buy properties you get your
bit of income coming in fine and you
definitely try to comply to be free
you're buying properties and you get
these little deals and you're scrapping
around making a few hundred pound
airfield upon there but then suddenly
the market changes yeah yeah and
suddenly it's like oh goodness there's
little tiny properties that Walt would
give me a little bit of income I've now
gone right up in value
yeah and then you sell one and then back
you start doing some big deals yeah and
that's when you suddenly get very
wealthy and I think in real life I think
that's true to say as well which is I
don't know if you'd agree been in the
game for two decades I would and you're
right and we we start off with very
small properties and yeah we've got a
couple learn a little bit bigger now and
I think that's you know what the kitchen
a bathroom cost will be exactly the same
on a forty five thousand pound house two
hundred fifty thousand pounds so
although there is nothing about yield
and return on the property there is also
a case that you know the value you can
add to a larger house it doesn't cost
you much yeah and if it's an area where
you're expecting good capital growth
yeah actually it's worth doing yes I
mean yeah absolutely
I mean I like when I started that buying
I was buying very very cheap properties
very small properties simply because
well for a start I wouldn't be able to
afford it
to buy even a house that was two hundred
thousand pounds the returns are better
but there's pros and cons
yeah and you can really you could really
argue it both ways what have been the
what have been the biggest sort of
successes then and the real highlights
of your property journey over there yeah
I'm gonna think I think the one big
thing that's made them ruler to me is
budgeting and you
it's a bit boring I mean you know my
strategy could be seen from it's very
boring I'm not gonna love Cory
absolutely it's very boring and a
bashing so porn and you know what yeah
when I when I went on your crash course
one of the very first things you talked
about was the six bank account model and
as soon as you mention that you have
more interest because I've never seen
that before but you know what I was
doing it if you do it for years we've
not quite the same but I mean we've got
two different bank accounts in every
Marvel all that money goes into one
account and then it pings out
automatically to all these other
accounts yeah and that's everything
covered we know where we are with
everything yeah and you know what if
people did that I think that fine
they've got more money at the end of the
month to say to put into it just to
clarify water because I know some people
watch this might not be into the crash
course sure because we you're talking
about the simple version would be rather
than saying here's my wage and I'm gonna
try and save what's left and invest it's
you need to pay yourself first so yeah
it's that it we almost flipped that on
his head at the crash course and teach
the money management system whereby
magically you'll have more money and
you're cuz cuz Oh mother I had a guy who
was making three thousand pounds a month
and he wasn't saving any money he said
he couldn't afford to save money a kid
he had a wife and then he got a pay rise
yeah and he said Samuel I'm now making
three thousand five hundred and what I'm
gonna do is I wanna put that farm in
Japan and I'm gonna say them to put that
in property I said good for you that's
it six months later I said how's your
free ground hmm
he said well I said how's your three
ground he's like I said well six months
ago you said you'd say for him to pound
you must have three grand now how does
it do it
he was like oh yeah mmm he said it's
interesting that because when I got my
pay rise suddenly cost-of-living seemed
to match it yeah and that's what happens
but in less you budget properly unless
you pay yourself first you're never
gonna have spare money you're never
gonna happen with mine to invest in
property so that's that's a really
really good point
what would you say moving forward
you focus is gonna be on now that for
you still sure yeah I think it's to be
decided I think I mean there'll be more
property
yeah I imagine I probably will do
another single let do you know what your
paw depends on what comes along yeah
I've got all the right move sets up I'm
constantly looking so I've got my pouch
I know where I'm looking and I've done
that by researching yeah so make sure to
fit my strategy yeah those not too far
away that context you get to it but it
is in the growth area and now it's about
what comes along so you know I look at
all sorts of things I look at a 4-bit
detached just before Christmas in that
area because it was actually on for a
really good price yeah so different
strategy for that but equally if there's
a too big single leg it's gonna make top
cent and it's not a lot of money I'll
probably go for that yeah interesting
that you haven't review think what
conditional investor yeah you haven't
stopped into your area have you have you
do invest in different areas yeah but
the one you're buying at the moment is
nowhere near where you live what do you
think of that from a management point of
view talk to me about talk to me about
how do you buy properties that are
really far away from where you live how
does that work
okay so just going back a little bit
from that so the reason that occurred
was I actually left my job just before
George Osborne stood up and there now
it's closed 24 we had all individually
owned really well-paid job I know this
is great big hammer that's gonna come
down so I needed a new strategy and
that's what I think that working here do
we set up where we go
yeah there's no way all that hard work
of gonna sell it all
so we descend right okay what we're
gonna do it we're gonna set up a limited
company we're gonna start by for them to
company and just build a new portfolio
and that one will be a limited company
that'll offset any losses we've got so
that's how it happened and then as well
they don't work you know hunt for cheer
anymore you can't buy a property in
Hartford sheer as a single that
certainly and let it out and make a
decent return yeah so that's how it cuts
so I started looking up I started work
in a hole in Manchester and I had all
these alerts set up and I had all these
emails come in and asked what I didn't
know where was it going to go
no focus what he students actually find
my area so what kind of area one looking
for and I wanted growth I wanted
somewhere that looked like it's got a
wealthy area but they'll still meet you
there and somewhere with a lots of
development go so yeah hs2 is going into
crew crew is right next to sound like
it's a really good spot longer-term if
you look online as stuff they're gonna
do crew station it's looking like
reading I mean it's gonna be fantastic
it's going really really modern retail
Catholic bars all that kind of stuff so
you look like a really good area for the
future so I thought right that's my area
today and that's how it occurred now
obviously being three hours away I can't
manage those properties like you just
stop you there by the way I just Willis
I love what you just said that's stuff
that you should definitely if you're
watching this rewind the losses that
gank about the labs are really in about
how you found the area include what you
look for real real golden look at their
so respect for that talk to me about
management yeah so the once ourself we
we use agent to find tenants the owner
manager after that yeah and you know
what I don't spend much time I it's it's
I've got a good team around me so how
did you put that team together I mean
the gas you an electrician they've been
with me for years they actually that she
did work on an extension at our house
about 20 years but did they do the same
use the same people that work for you in
Hartford sure and crow know except for
the painter is gonna paint the house and
crew for us okay but how did you put
together your new teaming crew yeah so
the first thing was when I was going out
there looking at properties I picked up
the local newspapers and there's a
couple of think new local magazines and
things out there so you're looking at
that I'm looking at people's names and
kids and I found so mad and I thought
okay that looks interesting bring the
guy up
he's actually wife she manages his diary
is a kitchen pizza sampler okay but just
you know you want to do a bit of
research find what he's doing I've got
an account with hounds for kitchens oh
yeah my kitchen
at the moment and in down south a rain
housing crew and they knew this guy and
he had a good reputation so I'm crazy
yeah got a really good kisser fitter I
did the same thing with the other guys
so built this team just by putting
together people from getting making sure
they've got good reputation in the area
and then on the very first project I was
up there to the duration so I was
keeping an eye on it I was doing other
work outside of that so it wasn't
costing me too much time but I was in
there every day just keep an eye and
make sure we come together and then
after that it's fine it was given the
keys they know the brief yeah on the one
we're doing next week I arrived there
with my son on day one all the
deliveries come in so the kitchen
arrived the bathroom arrived everything
else arrives the carpets get measured
and can't dry everything happens and
then I hand the keys over to the
tradespeople and they deal with it so
it's it's really not entirely hands off
because no you're managing yourself but
you do it from a distance
yeah and you've got good people in the
area that can do that to drive to the
property
no but you you didn't witness to
something that's really good nothing
that makes a lot of sense and these
things that were talked about an hour
just so vitally important especially if
you are losing managing yourself I mean
I don't think that buying in your area
just because your area is actually that
small personally because if it's not a
good investment area it's great if it
happens to be yeah we're trying to put
fear square peg in a round hole and make
it fit
just because you live there you getting
a bit burn on a whole portfolio just
because you live there and then wanting
to move yeah yeah the markets change you
know whenever you first started well it
just happened to be a good area yeah
yeah you know we've got the ripple
effect from London it was brilliant but
it's not now and I think a lot of people
find the same thing why people are
looking further up north and yeah if you
want to make some money you've got to do
that yeah yeah
so I mean you yeah and I think the
things were talking about are really
important you said a few times if I knew
then what I know now
yeah about training
because all song has been in the game a
long time it's really you know it's
quite humbling for me that you've been
in the game a lot longer than I have
yeah but then you come on to be trained
by me and then come to my programs why
do you feel it's important to do that
even as someone who's got experience you
know it's not just in porn but actually
I never want to stop learning you know I
think maybe before that you know we're
not in the day job there's always this
learning going on to trainee cause you
sense I'm all this kind of stuff and
then you come out and suddenly you're on
your own and you think well where am I
going to get that input from and I mean
that's how it came across years you know
sound John Lyon I thought was you know
that's what he's doing is relevant and
current and that's that's the point so
it's about it's about enjoying that
learning journey but also getting
something out of it hopefully
implementing it and improving my
business at the same time yeah fantastic
and what would you say to somebody that
was considering registering for the
krassnoff what was it like what would
you say to them stop considering do it
be the message I mean yeah I'll tell you
when we're knowing Tommy I brought my
wife oh well I stopped it - she actually
said she wanted but she was doing for me
she was so fired up after that cause I
could believe it I mean you know Sally I
love it dearly and she's not she's not a
business person it's not what she wants
it's not what she does but furtive come
back with so much enthusiasm off that
course is amazing yeah yeah if you if
you want to get you know you inspired
and you want to you know start your
journey or
you're already on your journey just got
to go to the course there's so much
value there yeah I really appreciate
that it means a lot coming from you and
thanks so much we've got on the show and
looking forward to seeing how you get on
with your crew properties I hopefully
hate your motivation Sisto god bless
thanks so much
hello Cheers yes thank you so much for
watching the video that is the reason
why I'm doing this your success is my
oxygen every single week we've got
people becoming financially free if
you'd like to see more success units you
can do that right here but what I'd
really suggest is why don't you come and
join us at the property investors crash
course comment on my guest completely
free and I'll personally be there for
two days to help you get started you can
see what happens right here what you'll
notice is all of these stories they all
start at the crash course so come along
my guests can't wait to see you there
peace out